>> Tucker: REMEMBER THE BLM
MOVEMENT, MAY OF 2020, WHEN
EVERY HIGH SCHOOL GIRL IN
AMERICA WAS REQUIRED TO PUT A
BLACK SQUARE ON HER INSTAGRAM
PAGE?
REMEMBER THAT.
BLM, EVERYONE IS FOR BLM.
MITT ROMNEY MARCHED WITH BLM.
WHAT WAS THAT?
IT WAS A SCAM, ACTUALLY, IT
TURNS OUT.
IT WAS A SCAM.
IT HURT THE COUNTRY.
CANDACE OWENS HAS DONE A
DOCUMENTARY ON THIS.
THERE WAS A VIDEO ON INSTAGRAM
COMPLAINING ABOUT CANDACE OWENS'
REPORTING.
WATCH THIS.
>> SO WE ARE HEADED THERE.
WE'RE YET TO SEE BLACK PEOPLE IN
THIS NEIGHBORHOOD.
THERE'S DEFINITELY SOMEBODY
HOME.
HELLO.
I WAS JUST LOOKING TO SPEAK TO
WHOEVER IS AT THIS PROPERTY.
SIR?
HELLO?
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S GOING TO
GET SOMEONE.
I SEE A VERY CUTE GERMAN
SHEPHERD IT LOOKS LIKE.
>> THIS MORNING I WOKE UP TO
CANDACE OWENS BEING OUTSIDE MY
HOUSE WITH A NEWS CREW.
>> I CAN'T SEE HOW THIS PURCHASE
HELPED BLACK LIVES ANYWHERE IN
AMERICA.
I CAN'T EVEN FIND A BLACK LIFE
ON THE PROPERTY.
THE DOG IS NOT EVEN BLACK.
SO THERE'S THAT.
>> SO THEY'RE LITERALLY TRYING
TO DESTROY US.
THEY'RE TRYING TO DESTROY ME.
THEY'RE TRYING TO DESTROY THE
MOVEMENT.
I REALLY -- I JUST NEED US TO BE
STRONGER.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU LIVE IN A
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR HOME IN
LAUREL CANYON, IT CAN BE HARD.
CANDACE OWENS IS THE PERSON WHO
CAUSED THE SUFFERING YOU JUST
SAW, THE PRODUCER OF BRAND-NEW
DOCUMENTARY.
ONE OF THE BRAVEST PEOPLE WE
KNOW, ONE OF THE SMARTEST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS.
THAT WHOLE MOMENT IS FORGOTTEN.
WHY DID YOU THINK IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO MAKE A DOCUMENTARY
ABOUT IT?
>> BECAUSE OF EXACTLY WHAT YOU
SAID, BECAUSE THEY WANT YOU TO
FORGET IT, RIGHT?
THEY DA THESE THINGS, SORT OF
PUMP YOU IN THE FACE, AND MOVE
ON.
THEY SAY, NOBODY LOOK ANY
FURTHER.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO A DIFFERENT
NARRATIVE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO PAUSE,
REFLECT, ASK A VERY BIG
QUESTION, WHICH NO JOURNALIST
WAS INTERESTED IN AT THE TIME.
WE WERE REQUIRED TO PUT UP A
BLACK SQUARE OR DONATE TO BLACK
LIVES MATTER, MAKE A STATEMENT
ON LINE ABOUT HOW BLACK PEOPLE
WERE SUFFERING, SO BLACK LIVES
MATTER WOULD RECEIVE $80 MILLION
IN ONE YEAR.
NOBODY ASKED WHERE THE MONEY WAS
GOING.
THEY TURNED ME INTO PUBLIC ENEMY
NUMBER ONE FOR TALKING ABOUT
GEORGE FLOYD, NOT IN THE
CAPACITY OF A HERO, BUT HAD
ENOUGH FENTANYL IN HIS SYSTEM TO
MAKE HIM DIE.
THAT MADE PEOPLE ANGRY, BECAUSE
THEY WERE INVESTED IN BLACK
LIVES MATTER.
THEY ROBBED AMERICANS.
THEY ROBBED AMERICANS' EMOTIONS,
EXTRACTED EMOTIONS, USED BLACK
PAIN TO CREATE CONFUSION AND
TAKE MILLIONS UPON MILLIONS,
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE FROM
PEOPLE.
WHERE DID THE MONEY GO?
THE DOCUMENTARY EXPLORES.
PEOPLE WILL BE SHOCKED.
I HOPE PEOPLE ARE BEHIND THE
TRANSGENDER MOVEMENT, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF THIS MONEY
WENT.
THEN THERE'S A DEAD TRAIL.
ONE THING YOU'RE AFFORDED, WHEN
YOU DECIDE YOU'RE TRANSGENDER,
YOU CAN CHANGE YOUR NAME.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHO THESE PEOPLE
WERE ORIGINALLY, BUT THEY
RECEIVED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN CASH.
>> Tucker: I CAN'T CONTROL
MYSELF.
I KNOW, BECAUSE I WAS THERE, AND
I WATCHED IT.
YOU WERE BASICALLY BANNED FROM
ALL MEDIA, INCLUDING
CONSERVATIVE OUTLETS FOR TELLING
THE TRUTH, THE FACTUAL
DOCUMENTED TRUTH ABOUT GEORGE
FLOYD.
YOU WERE NOT ALLOWED TO TELL THE
TRUTH, WHICH REALLY WAS --
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU, DO
YOU KNOW ANYBODY, APART FROM THE
LADIES LIVING IN LAUREL CANYON,
AND THE TRANSGENDERS YOU JUST
MENTIONED, ANY NORMAL BLACK
PERSON WHO BENEFITED FROM BLM?
>> NO.
IT'S THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
I CAN TELL YOU MILLIONS OF BLACK
PEOPLE WHO SUFFERED BECAUSE THEY
LIVE IN THE INNER CITIES THAT
WERE LOOTED AND RIOTED.
THEY PICKED UP LEFT, BECAUSE
CRIME IS ALLOWED TO TAKE PLACE,
AND THESE ARE ZONES IN WHICH
THERE CAN BE NO POLICING.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING
ECONOMICALLY, BECAUSE OF THE BLM
SCAM, WHICH BENEFITED NOBODY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
IN MY PERSONAL OPINION, THIS WAS
A MONEY LAUNDERING SCHEME.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS, DECIDED TO HOST A
JOE BIDEN INAUGURATION PARTY AT
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER HOUSE.
MY PERSONAL CHARITY, AFTER I
ANNOUNCED I WAS DOING THIS
DOCUMENTARY, WE RECEIVED A
LETTER TWO WEEKS AFTER THE
TRAILER DROPPED FROM THE IRS
SAYING THEY WERE GOING TO
INVESTIGATE MY CHARITY.
I WELCOMED THE INVESTIGATION,
BECAUSE I'M NOT A SCAM ARTIST.
I DO REAL WORK IN THE INNER CITY
COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS BIDEN'S IRS ONCE AGAIN
SAYING YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
INVESTIGATE ANYTHING THAT THE
MEDIA IS COMPLICIT IN.
>> Tucker: THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
YOU'RE A BRAVE PERSON.
THEY'RE GOING TO COME FOR YOU AT
SOME POINT, AS YOU KNOW.
CANDACE OWENS, APPRECI